you
in today's morning rounds we're looking
at the safety of beauty face masks amid
a recall the skincare brand yes to
voluntarily recalled it's grapefruit
vitamin the siglo boosting unicorn paper
mask yes that's the whole name this
follows reports of burning redness and
painful skin irritation it's a big name
we talked to Damien bee and her 13 year
old daughter her name is Olivia they're
from Louisiana she and other users told
us a mass burned but say they kept it on
because a package says tingling yes it's
working obviously initially I was a
little bit worried that it was something
that's gonna have lasting effects it was
it was bright red she was worried she
came out almost in tears and they like
stung if he touched it so I had to keep
like a cool rattling boy the makers of
the Mass es2 released a statement saying
in part quote while our products are all
independently tested for safety
irritation and allergy the safety and
satisfaction of our customers are our
main concerns as such we've decided to
pull this particular product off the
shelves while we investigate
dermatologist that's dr. Elizabeth Hale
joins us at the table to discuss we
should say welcome dr. hill good to have
you back we should say that their
product uses 95% of natural ingredients
and they say that they avoid harmful
chemicals and most people think if it
says natural that that's a good thing
you don't have to worry but if it says
tingling it's okay
I wouldn't that wouldn't raise a red
flag that is a little misleading because
I think lling is not necessarily a good
thing
and similarly natural is not always a
good thing there's a real crazed right
now in the beauty industry for clean
beauty with natural skincare
representing at least 25% of the very
much growing skincare market the issue
is although natural products can be good
and can have benefits when they're used
in very high concentrations like in this
case here in a sheet mask there are
ingredients like citric acid which can
be very irritating to the skin so I
think maybe a little misleading so I
think we need to know that certain
products although they are natural and
may have benefits to the skin oftentimes
these natural products contain essential
oils which can be very irritating
especially under a mask
that increases penetration so some of
these products do have skin benefits but
we need to make sure especially in cases
like this we need to make sure our
children are being supervised because
some of this marketing is directly
toward this my next question which is
there's a you there's a unicorn unicorn
in the name unicorn on the package the
mother of the rainbow
yeah the mother of the child we talked
to said she felt it was being marketed
to kids is it safe for kids so I think
you know math can be a good thing they
can be relaxing I'm actually having a
spa party for my daughter tomorrow so
you know I think it's nice that we're
getting old is your daughter's turning 9
we're getting children interested in
skincare I think the issue is though
without reading the ingredients without
knowing that things even like grapefruit
and orange can be very irritating to do
so a lavender lavender so some of these
products that can have beneficial
effects anything used in high
concentrations can be very irritating so
what should people do if they have a
reaction so the first thing to do is to
discontinue the mask if it is tingling
it should be taken off right away
because that I don't think that that's a
good sign to remove the products and
then there are some soothing ingredients
like castor bean oil and glycerin
another thing to mention is to keep this
damaged skin out of the Sun because
sometimes these products induce a photo
allergic reaction which means your skin
is irritated and very Sun sensitive do
you think they work that was the last
question I think sheet masks can be very
hydrating to the skin so any type of
mask has an occlusive effect where
you're actually covering the skin so
some products like hyaluronic acid which
is very hydrating that can be helpful in
my practice I use them when patients are
recovering from procedures like laser
procedures they can help with hydration
birth of your daughter Elizabeth Hale
thanks very much
you